[Música]
expectativas sobre el aborto en Estados
Unidos el presidente joeyden prometió
que presentará una ley para garantizar
el derecho a la interrupción del
embarazo y que su partido logra quedarse
con el control del congreso en las
elecciones de medio término luego de que
este fuera revocado por la corte
Superior
tras el anuncio migratorio de Estados
Unidos que no admitirá migrantes
venezolanos llegados por tierra miles
quedaron varados en México y otros
países de paso sin protección y sin
opciones tras haber recorrido el
continente les contamos
se cumplen tres años del estallido
Social que sacudió a Chile e impulsó un
proceso constitucional en este
aniversario el presidente Gabriel borich
reconoció que no se han concretado las
demandas más importantes se hizo un
llamado Aliado
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en Francia 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Estados Unidos faltan 21 días para las
elecciones de medio mandato y el
presidente joeyden aseguró que su
administración presentará una ley para
consagrar el derecho al aborto si los
demócratas ganan en estos comicios el
mandatario prometió que si su partido
consigue un mayor número de sillas en el
senado y mantiene el control de la
cámara pedirá la aprobación de una
normativa que proteja a nivel Federal la
interrupción del embarazo algo que quedó
revocado luego de que la Corte Suprema
derogara la icónica sentencia del caso
Row versus weight
quiero repetirlo de nuevo la única vía
para detener estas leyes extremistas que
ponen en peligro la salud y los derechos
de las mujeres es que el congreso
apruebe una ley y lo he dicho antes la
corte acertó con Row hace casi 50 años y
creo que el congreso debería codificar
Row de una vez por todas en este momento
nos faltan un puñado de votos
[Aplausos]
si te importa el derecho a elegir
Entonces tienes que votar
también en Estados Unidos el presidente
Joe biden librará 15 millones de
barriles de petróleo de las reservas
estratégica después de los recortes de
la OPEP más el mandatario continuará
vendiendo barriles de las reservas de
emergencia de la nación hasta diciembre
y presentar un plan este miércoles para
volver a llenar el almacenamiento a
precios más Bajos en un intento por
estimular la producción
tras el anuncio migratorio de Estados
Unidos que no admitirá migrantes
venezolanos llegados por tierra miles
quedaron parados en México y otros
países de paso sin protección y sin
opciones tras haber recorrido el
continente desde México nuestro
corresponsal Mario carbonell nos habla
de la situación en la nación Azteca
la situación para los migrantes
venezolanos en México se complica cada
día más esto a raíz del acuerdo
alcanzado entre los gobiernos de México
y Estados Unidos mediante el cual la
administración de Joe biden ofrece
24.000 visas a venezolanos que lleguen a
ese país por vía aérea mientras que
aquellos que intenten ingresar por vía
terrestre serán deportados serán
regresados y serán acogidos por México
de manera temporal esto tiene al país
con las estaciones migratorias y los
albergues al borde del colapso es el
caso de la ciudad fronteriza de Tijuana
Baja California ahí el director de
atención al migrante Enrique Lucero dijo
a Franz 24 que hasta este lunes han
recibido a 552 migrantes de nacionalidad
venezolana que en promedio desde el
pasado 13 de octubre a la fecha han
recibido entre 100 y 120 migrantes pero
que el día lunes recibieron hasta 200
ahí en esa ciudad en Tijuana se realizó
una protesta por parte de migrantes y
activistas este lunes en la que quemaron
dos piñatas una con el rostro o la
fotografía de Anthony blinken secretario
de estado de Estados Unidos y otra con
la del canciller mexicano Marcelo ebrard
en Ciudad Juárez también están en los
albergues a su máxima capacidad y
también hay inconformidades Asimismo en
Aguascalientes en un albergue hubo un
motín de emigrantes venezolanos y
lograron escapar 41 pero no nada más es
en las fronteras o en otros estados
sobre todo aquí en la Ciudad de México
también se puede ver a cientos de
migrantes venezolanos varados en las
estaciones de autobuses o afuera de las
oficinas de la comisión mexicana de
ayuda a refugiados la situación se torna
compleja se le ha cuestionado al
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador a
este respecto pero hasta el momento no
ha dado una respuesta concreta
y en Guatemala las autoridades también
intensificaron la interceptación de
migrantes venezolanos luego de la
decisión de Estados Unidos más de 2000
han sido detenidos en octubre en un
esfuerzo de las autoridades por frenar
La ola migratoria por Centroamérica
nuestro corresponsal en antigua
Guatemala Andrés Suárez Jaramillo tiene
los detalles
Aunque el flujo exacerbado de migrantes
venezolanos por Guatemala no es nuevo la
respuesta de las autoridades por
contenerlo sí lo es desde este fin de
semana se han intensificado los
operativos de las fuerzas policiales y
militares para impedir el curso de
venezolanos irregulares que buscan
cruzar Guatemala bien sea por el camino
paralelo a la costa Caribe o bien sea
por el camino central atravesando ciudad
de Guatemala y es que el anuncio de
Estados Unidos de deportar a los
venezolanos que cruzan ilegalmente la
frontera Sur en vilgó sobre las
autoridades guatemaltecas una suerte de
responsabilidad de filtro para decantar
el Éxodo de venezolanos de Suramérica
hacia Norteamérica en lo corrido de
octubre se han realizado más de 3000
detenciones capturas de las cuales el
80% corresponde a venezolanos que ahora
enfrentarán un proceso de deportación
ahora bien un venezolano que quisiera
cruzar legalmente Guatemala tendría que
para una visa tipo c la cual tiene
múltiples requisitos como contar con un
billete de avión pasaporte familiares
aquí en Guatemala y dado que la mayoría
no cuenta con esos requisitos se da a la
penosa tarea de someterse a las
maniobras de extorsión por parte de
agentes de la Policía Nacional que por
50 dólares los dejan cruzar hasta
territorio mexicano Y a partir de allí
comenzar un nuevo vía crucis migratorio
un viernes 18 de octubre de 2019 unas
estudiantes saltaron los torniquetes en
el metro Desatando las masivas protestas
sociales en Chile las demandas se
extendieron al tiempo que aumentó la
represión de las fuerzas de seguridad
Este martes en el tercer aniversario del
estallido Social las demandas de los
manifestantes Siguen sin atenderse pese
a la llegada de la izquierda Gabriel
borich al palacio de la moneda Marina
sardiña nos hace un repaso
Todo comenzó con este salto en el metro
de Santiago que resultó en el estallido
social más grande de la historia de
chile durante semanas millones de
chilenos Se tomaron las avenidas para
exigir al gobierno del expresidente
Sebastián Piñera mejoras en Salud
Educación vivienda pensiones tres años
después Muchas de sus demandas siguen
desatendidas así como la búsqueda de
justicia y reparación Para los 33
muertos y más de 400 heridos con
lesiones oculares la mayoría a manos de
las fuerzas de seguridad todavía
mantiene múltiples deudas en primer
lugar porque respecto al esclarecimiento
de los hechos y a que haya Justicia La
verdad es que el panorama es bien
desolador tenemos una situación de mucha
impunidad de las 10.831 víctimas que
denunciaron haber sido objeto de algún
tipo de violación de Derechos Humanos
durante ese período la revuelta social
también derivó en la exhalación de una
convención para la redacción de una
nueva constitu chilena para reemplazar
así la Carta Magna impuesta por los
militares durante la época del dictador
Augusto pinochet la misma que hace un
mes y medio fue rechazada por el
electorado el no ganó con el 62% de los
votos el estallidos social expresó y
trajo consigo mucho dolor y ha dejado
enormes secuelas
no vamos a permitir que sea en vano
no podemos ser los mismos como sociedad
después de esta experiencia no podemos
cometer los mismos errores ni quedarnos
arrinconados en nuestras cómodas veredas
en el tercer aniversario algunos
manifestantes volvieron a las calles
también se movilizaron unos 25.000
uniformados mientras la promesa de un
nuevo acuerdo social sigue en el aire y
el descontento Hacia El Ejecutivo
chileno aumenta
en otras noticias de América Latina el
presidente brasileño Jair bolsonaro
volvió a la ciudad de lluís defora
semina gerais donde fue puñalado hace
cuatro años y allí hizo campaña de Cara
a la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales del domingo 30 de octubre
el mandatario también se disculpó por
los comentarios en los que sugería que
un grupo de menores venezolanas eran
prostitutas por su parte medios de
comunicación locales reportaron que el
candidato izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva podría no asistir al próximo
debate argumentando falta de agenda para
participar del encuentro
y en Venezuela las lluvias no dan tregua
y siguen causando destrucción en la
región central del país al menos tres
personas murieron por el desbordamiento
de un río en el estado de aragua el
presidente de Venezuela Nicolás Maduro
se trasladó hasta el lugar donde dispuso
a 300 soldados para iniciar las labores
de recuperación y apoyo en las zonas
afectadas además pidió a las autoridades
movilizar a tropas militares de estado
cercanos para sumar ayuda
hasta que este Informativo en francés 24
Gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]